NARRATOR: September 11,
2001, terror strikes
set the tone for warfare
in the 21st century.
But the 21st century
has also seen the rise
of another kind of warfare--
warfare that lets
nations and loners
do battle without guns or bombs.
These days, the
biggest threat we face
may be a rogue
actor with a laptop
and a desire to wreak havoc.
Cyberwarfare is probably
the greatest challenge
that we have as
far as our nation's
national security is concerned.
We have an advantage over
every other form of competition
with possible allies except
one, and that is cyberwarfare.
And when you see the
potential of what
a successful
cyber-attack can achieve,
it's enough to make
you deeply concerned.
This is going to be
the new battlefield--
an unseen invisible
battlefield--
where teams of hackers from
various nations will duel.
In 2010, a computer
virus named "Stuxnet"
demolished a secret Iranian
nuclear weapons plant.
Hackers at Symantec Corporation
unraveled its mysteries.
What made Stuxnet different
was it didn't just stick
to the cyber world, it actually
reached and caused sort
of real world kinetic damage.
It's nothing that we
had ever seen before.
And so Stuxnet just began
spreading all around the world
onto Windows
machines everywhere.
But what it was doing
was, it was also
looking for something else.
It was looking for these
things that are called PLCs,
or these small computers that
control things like factories,
like the power grid.
What you see here is the
code that is put on to the PLC,
and this is the normal process
code goes on to the PLC
turns the PLC on or
off and controls it.
When we first got the code,
it's literally zeros and ones.
It's sort of unintelligible.
It was only later that we were
able to determine that actually
this code was targeted,
specifically, at Iran's uranium
enrichment plant in Natanz.
LIAM O'MURCHU: Uranium
enrichment facilities
are very secure facilities.
It's not like they're
connected to the internet.
You can't get your code
in and out in that way.
So one of the ways
that Stuxnet was
able to get into the
facility was via USB key.
So it was able to
infect USB keys,
and then somebody would
bring the USB key with them
into the secure facility not
realizing it was infected,
plug into a computer inside,
and then that computer
inside would be infected.
We don't know definitively
who is behind Stuxnet,
but it's very clear that
it's a nation state,
and it's nation states that
had something against Iran,
and it's likely that it
isn't a single nation state.
And remember, as well, with
cyberwarfare that the barrier
to entry is quite low.
If a country wants
to do something
like build a nuclear
missile, that's actually
quite difficult. But when
you talk about something
like cyberwarfare, it's actually
quite cheap and quite easy
for a country to
develop a cyber weapon,
and that cyber weapon can
have equivalent effects.
You can have a cyber
weapon potentially
shut down the power
grid, for example,
on the whole east coast.
New York is out.
Wall Street is out.
All your banks are out.
You can't even withdraw money.
You can imagine people--
panic starting-- and
people trying to get cash.
You can't get cash.
ATMs aren't working.
And then things like your water
waste and treatment plants
aren't working,
so no clean water.
There's going to
be a run on stores.
Stores potentially
aren't even operating.
Your credit card is not
going to work at the store.
There will be
absolutely mass panic.
If you can blind
the US military--
if you could shut down our
GPS and our computer networks,
our military is basically
unable to function.
And it could take days or
weeks to get those systems
back up and running.
They can do tremendous damage.
They can defeat your armies,
your fleets, your Air Forces,
by simply blinding
them-- by taking
down their cyber systems.
I think that's a huge
risk that we face.
With cyberwar, I always think
one of the most effective ways
to fighting in cyber, is to find
the computer and the operator
and put a bullet
through both of them.